welcome to this video playing Yardbird
one of the all-time all-time great
opponents here I don't we I really like
to know how many games he has played
let's let's just briefly check this
50,000 five-minute games Wow I also have
quite a substantial amount of games but
this is really a lot ok let's let's see
we buy transposition got to to a
symmetrical English if you place deform
ok didn't maybe is playing for slower
set up with e3 ok try to get this
exchanged so now simple maybe play t5 I
don't have an especially great square
for for the night a 5s are questionable
getting back to be eight hmm don't know
taketake jump taking on defaults never a
good idea really
hmm yeah I'd really don't like the
position i must admit that where to go
with the snide now he can even take a
plane idea for ya I don't know really I
don't like it probably my hair would set
up is not so great with the Sun this
trading maneuver on age three
asics obviously tries to play be five
but that's not so easy to do yeah
especially if he just keep the tension
like he's doing now with Queenie too
yeah I can I have some rather
non-committal moves that strengthen my
position bid just waiting just waiting
for him to to do something but it's not
very very nice to play yeah I think I
would play d5 if I was wide d5 any form
yeah now that's not not bad at all
interesting way to play maybe here
intending is six ok
check yeah I go f6 this is really a
weakness so just just retreat at least
I'm not far behind on the clock that's a
slight hope yeah okay come on let's do
that the sea pong match might get weak
but it's hard too hard to do this
without any sort of activity at least
rookie one I can probably take a problem
in this position is also exactly h4 I
was just about to say that this is this
can be a problem I cannot allow him to
play age 5 and this is a weak structure
night F or something not a 495 and any
kind of sacrifice at least there are
some pieces traded already so it's not
like he can attack with full force it's
not so easy to improve them for me the
night only 70 s must cover ever see 5 I
don't really have many moves Queen B
seven maybe but it's not that's not
doing so much as well we'd really like
to get rid of the night here with e6 but
we also always has Knight f6 they are
the good thing is in a way that is a
very active player and he's not doing
any sit and wait stuff he will come
after you after you value himself who
came intending 95
using the pin on the long diagonal if I
go if I go Knight f6 Roxy 594 yeah maybe
chamber this is not really connected to
a plan still night before or the same
sacrifice no let's do that cannot spend
minutes on that
yeah looks nice but is it doing much all
right tech here very tricky to play I'm
not even attacking this how idiotic is
that I thought I were taking the night
which is really stupid okay at least it
it's not blundering anything immediately
least I hope very tense position
maybe you should just retreat oh yeah i
was i was thinking about that but I
didn't think it's working at least not
objectively speaking Czech no no
diverland at this nonsense no this was
this was very good for blood just not
this bloody King yeah he's got rooked g5
and that's deadly
ah that's a shame that's a shame this
was entirely correct to sacrifice really
yeah black resigns yeah that was very
silly very silly play by me I don't I
don't believe in this at all I just need
to do something else here let's see or
hear I don't I don't believe this not
really it doesn't have any looks in play
okay the computers is all about equal
with 95 this is really this is really
losing directly a dad which is just
member spent them just in just a couple
of seconds here this I can do yeah I
mean this is just just okay yeah okay it
was not a bad sacrifice I was thinking
that it's just nonsense but it isn't but
I must play justice just idiotic why did
I take this so quickly four seconds yeah
that's bad yeah i thought i did i really
didn't think about 95 yeah this this
should be okay and i can I can defend my
king at least easily the the whole staff
was very very complicated and yeah maybe
here I should take this is also possible
just take here and play play with the
eight or something this actually
threatens 92 not bad I guess it was
around equal very tense position with
all those nights in the center and yeah
I had had some some weird ideas because
I have talked here I was rethinking this
was detected isn't
so I a bad idea yeah very very
complicated game but taking us probably
just better I was I was really thinking
if this is hanging it isn't no it isn't
of course then I just played this this
too quickly okay thanks for watching